[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and at San Diego
comic-con the writers of Avengers
endgame have officially revealed how
tannaz killed the Avengers in the
original script throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
they said as well as how the deaths were
originally planned to play out and
giving my thoughts on the repercussions
of it there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you're the last person on earth
who hasn't seen Avengers endgame and I
highly recommend that you turn the video
off now and go straight to the cinema to
watch the re-release yes even the one
with the terrible hulk scene in it if
you're still here i just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking the video
now let's get into my breakdown of how
dannis was going to originally murder
the Avengers in endgame okay so the two
writers of Avengers endgame Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely recently had
a panel at comic-con in which they
discussed the writing process of the
movie balancing the timeline and the
original things that ended up on the
cutting room floor this included a huge
thing that would have left many fans
more upset than watching Tony Stark say
I love you 3,000 to Morgan at his own
funeral and yet even reading it kind of
had me a bit shocked so in the scene we
followed 2014 Danis who had learned all
the ins and outs of his history through
the recording device embedded in nebulas
head with this knowledge Thanos then
traveled to earth and brutally killed
all of the Avengers wiping them out
pretty easily as at this point they were
all very inexperienced in the scene
after their defeat at his hands Danis
would pick up Captain America and wait
for it
decapitate him to get it like decapitate
never mind anyway upon arriving at
Avengers HQ in 2023 with his
re-engineered Pym particle for the
climax of the movie Dallas would throw
Captain America's severed head at the
present Captain America to show that he
wasn't messing around now I don't think
this was in the script but I really hope
he said something like I went for the
head time to head off
we will not had to be davit ah I should
have just stuck with the cap
anyway this scene was obviously meant to
marathon us being beheaded earlier in
the film and basically it shows now that
unlike infinity war Dan ass is not here
to spare lives
remember endgame Thanos is the one who
famously said in all my years of
conquest violence slaughter it was never
personal but I tell you now what I'm
about to do to you stubborn annoying
little planet I'm gonna enjoy it
very very much this scene would kind of
build upon that and show that he was
taking a lot of pleasure from going
around and killing the Avengers remember
Dan ass has Cena he's already won and in
his mind he's inevitable so at this
point he's just toying around with
everyone and having fun because he knows
that he's gonna destroy the universe
this was meant to massively shake the
Avengers and it's a good tactic to get
in their heads
put intended and it would have also
brought Tony Stark's fish in from
Avengers and game full circle and have
been a nice little nod to that movie
in the end though Disney cut because
they thought it was far too violent and
also that fans would be confused by how
Captain America was dead and also alive
this would be because every time
something happens in the past it creates
an alternate timeline however a lot of
fans were confused over the mechanics of
it and this probably would have made the
plot for more muddled now obviously I
loved hear your thoughts on this reveal
and what you think of it would you have
liked to have seen it and do you think
that it would have worked
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the news that Brandon Roth is returning
to the role of Superman for CW's crisis
on Infinite Earths
I'll be covering the big stories from
Comic Con this weekend so make sure you
stay locked to the channel for more
updates I also just want to let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
Avengers endgame on blu-ray to one lucky
winner and all you have to do is like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and comment below with
your thoughts on this revealed scene the
one will be chosen at random on August
the 10th and the blu-ray will be shipped
out from there to ever get surprise so
thanks everyone for getting involved and
best of luck to you this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you